and speaking of a woman i really don't
like here's aoc we have a crisis of
missing and um and murder indigenous and
black women in the united states
today i want to discuss part of this
crisis that is all too often overlooked
but whose evidence shows that there's a
very meaningful connection here the
correlation between fossil fuel
extraction sites and abductions and
murders of indigenous women across the
united states what the high hell do you
even want me to say about that what can
i even do with this i mean the woman is
purposely wearing big glasses to look
smart that's number one like she just
puts on the can i get the biggest
glasses possible the people are starting
to realize i'm an idiot
okay yes the big issue around fossil
fuels is something related to black
women and and indigenous people being
kidnapped or something like that these
people they are such unserious clowns
it's extreme i have nothing else to say
about that clip here's more on aoc she
did a little little was this a tick tock
or an inside i think it's an instagram
video
she's doing the biden whisper thing now
which is even creepier than when he does
it tell you a secret
most people don't really know what
capitalism is
most people don't even know what
socialism is
but most people are not capitalists
because they don't have capitalist money
they're not billionaires sometimes the
label doesn't matter as much as just
talking about policies that's easier to
understand
do you think people should die because
they can't afford insulin
do you think that fossil fuel ceo should
decide whether the planet gets set on
fire
meaning c word c word that's what she is
but i'm not gonna say it i'm not gonna
say it but that's what she is she is a
liar she is a full-blown socialist in
our government um and she is lying about
what capitalism is the idea that you
have to be a billionaire to be a
capitalist
i want you everybody watching this right
now everyone in this room gentlemen in
this room could we all think about our
grandparents for a second and our great
grandparents who all came here from
different places whether they came from
eastern europe or whether they came from
north africa
or whether they came from canada or
anywhere else the story of america is
people who basically came with nothing
came through ellis island or came
through some other border came with
nothing but a dream that there was a
place of freedom that was based on
capitalism the idea that if you work
hard that the government will get out of
your way enough so that you can live
freely
and that is the greatest
excuse me that is the greatest dream
just a sec have a hillary clinton moment
[Laughter]
um that is the greatest dream
that probably has ever happened in the
history of the world and she wants to
destroy that these people came here with
nothing and then you had an idea i'd
like to open up a restaurant
i'd like to
sell rubber bands i'd like to
whatever literally anything and you can
do it here and there's still a chance to
do it here and that's why we're still
the envy of the world and that's why
these socialists never leave
so she's a liar she's a socialist it's
an embarrassment that she's part of the
government
and uh
we got to vote these people out so that
we can end this national nightmare that
we are part of they are trying to upend
the economy they are trying to ruin the
thing
that is the greatest thing because they
hate the thing because they think they
own the world and they do not they do
not but if we give it to them they will
that's where we're at
[Music]
most people don't really know what
capitalism is
most people don't even know what
socialism is
but most people are not capitalists
because they don't have capitalist money
they're not billionaires the label
doesn't matter as much as just talking
about policies that's easier to
understand
do you think people should die because
they can't afford insulin no
you got the wrong house